tonight an officer shot while on duty
the suspect now dead this all happening
early this morning near flamingo and
university center drive madison
kimbrough is in the area tonight she
joins us live with the latest madison
yeah this happened just after 1am after
a metro police officer pulled over an
suv with several people inside you're
looking at the area of where it happened
now it's still unclear if there was any
type of verbal altercation but soon
after one of the men inside of the car
jumped out running the officer then
chased the man down and gunfire was
exchanged
both the officer and the suspect were
shot
the suspect was transported to sunrise
hospital and was pronounced
deceased the officer was transported to
university medical center trauma unit
and is currently in stable condition
[Applause]
it's still unknown what happened to the
other people in the car but according to
police this is the eighth
officer-involved shooting for metro this
year now at this point we still don't
know the name of the officer we are
awaiting those details reporting live
madison kimbrough 8 news now
now in regards to the officer involved
shooting president of the las vegas
police protective association steve
gramis said quote this morning was a
brutal reminder of what police officers
encounter one of our own was conducting
a routine traffic stop which turned into
a deadly encounter luckily our officer
while shot and injured was able to
return fire she is now in the care of
our medical professionals and will
recover